here now with more reaction is the
senator great state of South Carolina
Lindsey Graham is with a senator thank
you I did have an opportunity to speak
with you earlier today you believe
beyond any doubt they were trying to
kill Americans there was some ambiguity
on that tell us why you believe that
well I mean a third grader could figure
this out they were over running the
embassy they killed her contractor a
couple of days before
sulemani has been killing Americans for
twenty years he's on the ground and
Baghdad totally missed their target last
night yeah okay okay I'm sorry I thought
you were talking about whether or not we
had good Intel on killings Sulaimon
sulemani was up to no good he was
planning another attack a third grader
could figure that out last night I
always believed that they were trying to
kill Americans if you lob missiles
inside an airbase what's the intended
consequence to kill people inside the
airbase we're lucky we moved our people
out we had four hours notice but I said
last night I think it's more good
fortune than it was lack of intent but
here's the good news the president made
a very bold decision today to allow
things to calm down this speech will be
talked about long after his second term
this is on par would tear down this wall
mr. Gorbachev this is resetting the
relationship between the world and Iran
just not the United States the president
said there's an evil empire in Iran
that's bent on destroying the world
killing the people in Israel and coming
after us and now will no longer tolerate
it so this is on par with Reagan's tear
down this wall speech senator I there is
a day of reckoning but as we know
radicalism and we discussed this in some
detail last night a squared B squared C
squared radicalism with nuclear weapons
equals the potential for a modern-day
Holocaust that it we cannot ever as a
world let that happen
now let's assume the Iranian mullahs
cling to their rigid sick twisted ugly
evil ideology that would mean the world
has a day of reckoning ahead with the
intelligence if we ever get to the point
they're getting close that has to go
well
a conflict with Iran it will because
they chose the conflict the president
gave them an out I want you to do three
things I want you to change your
behavior stop being the largest state
sponsor of terrorism that's not too much
to ask
stand down your missile program because
you're destabilizing the entire Mideast
and you can have a nuclear power program
but you can't have a pathway to a bomb
those are the three conditions that the
president has laid down we Iran can meet
those conditions if they want to if they
choose to defy President Trump if they
choose to try to get a nuclear weapon
have a nuclear breakout if they choose
to continue to try to kill Americans in
the future they're basically writing
their own death warrant Donald Trump
will destroy their economy he will not
invade with land forces but the
ayatollahs regime will come to a fiery
end if they do not meet the conditions
set out by President Trump
I happen to like Rand Paul I happen to
like Senator Mike Lee and Mike Lee but I
don't agree with them on the War Powers
Act interpretation it would be very
clear President as commander in chief
has the right to defend the country and
not not immediately go to Congress you
actually went as far as to say they're
empowering the enemy with those
arguments why would they want to tie the
hands of our commander-in-chief that
they expect oh we've got an opportunity
here to take out Soleimani let me ask
Nancy Pelosi first well number one
they're great Patriots but you can't
have five you can't have 535
commander-in-chief's the War Powers Act
is unconstitutional there's only one
commander chief if you don't like the
action the commander chief is taking as
Congress you can defund those actions we
have control over the power of the purse
but they're they're great Americans but
when we get on the floor of the United
States Senate in the next couple weeks
in talking about restricting the ability
to deal with the religious Nazis in Iran
it will be seen by the Iranians as
division at home I hope we won't do it I
can't imagine doing this in World War
two and I'll end with this too the folks
listening
the Ayatollah has a plan and you're not
in it when he says I want to kill
destroy Israel he's not kidding
he's try
to purify the faith and in your eyes
he's an infidel and after 40 years of
terror you hadn't figured this out
you're just not looking very high you
and I are full agreement and by the way
this will not be a ground war it can't
be
last question you are now pushing
forward your resolution in the Senate as
it deals with Nancy Pelosi's well right
belief that she can influence and
dictate to the US Senate their
constitutional duty that's not going to
happen
the Pelosi impeachment dam has broken
you've had five Democrats come out today
and say send over the articles you said
it was urgent
if you believe it to be urgent send it
to the Senate for disposition she's
losing Democrats in the Senate the
impeachment damn of Nancy Pelosi is
about to crack hats off to Mitch
McConnell for playing this very well
we'll take the trial up next week okay
senator thank you we appreciate your
time you've been working overtime and
helping us inform this audience thank
you